>>Hi YouTube. I watched Pablo's video, and
I really agree with you that it's slightly
different for CEO's than for doctors and lawyers
and everything much to show you. But the point
that Pablo made. About the fact that making
money should never be the only consideration
is something which uh even the greatest proponent
of capitalism whether it's Adam Smith or Ang
Rahm made very clear. It's one thing to make
money while you're doing good for your company,
for your shareholders, your workers, and it's
another to make money while you're taking
you're company down the drain. This is really
what's been happening. We've had CEO's get
bonuses while their company has been saving
why the company has been failing. Look at
John (inaudible) redecorating his office to
the tune of a million dollars while getting
money from the taxpayers to bail out this
company. This is what should be unacceptable
and that's where a moral compass, a code of
ethics needs to prevail. So the rule should
be: don't make money for yourself in times
of (inaudible) or redecorating your office
or anything like that while you're taking
money from the taxpayers. And don't do it
while your company is going down the drain.
I think these are two very,very basic ethical
rules that our CEO's need to follow otherwise
they're becoming the Marie Antoinettes of
the economic (inaudible). Remember when we
read about Marie Antoinette we used to sort
of laugh how could she have possible had said
"Let them eat cake" when she was getting any,
and many of our CEO's aren't getting it either.